Pssst, c'est dimanche !
Il faut se lev... bah non faut pas se lever en fait !
Salut ! On est dimanche c'est votre jour de repos
Et c'est pas le mien parce que mon jour de repos ce sera
Le 1er janvier 2017
Le dimanche c'est le jour des explications
Et aujourd'hui je vais encore vous expliquer
Une technique, un truc, pour bluffer
Vos amis, votre famille, les gens que vous connaissez
Pour bluffer tout le monde !
Pour les abonnés qui suivent la chaîne
Vous remarquez que je suis habillé comme hier
Avec le même éclairage qu'hier
Dans le même cadre qu'hier
C'est parce que je fais cette vidéo hier...
Enfin moi je la fais aujourd'hui
Mais pour vous je la fais hier !
Puisque demain matin
Mais pour vous hier matin,
Je suis pas sûr à 100% de pouvoir filmer cette vidéo
Et de la monter là-bas
Donc dans la doute !
Et si vous n'êtes pas abonnés à la chaîne,
si vous ne voyez pas toutes ces vidéos que je met tous les jours sur Youtube
Pensez à cliquer là.
Fin de la parenthèse !
Je fais très bien les parenthèses, ok ?
Comme j'ai déjà fait dans certaines vidéos
Je vais vous faire l'effet à vous là, maintenant
Au travers de la caméra
On va le faire ensemble,
Je vais essayer de vous bluffer
Et ensuite vous n'aurez plus qu'à ré-appliquer la méthode
Pour bluffer les gens à votre tour !
Vous allez prendre 3 bouts de papier
3 post-it ou 3 bouts de papier que vous déchirez
Vous pouvez prendre une feuille de papier classique,
déchirer une bande vous la déchirez en 3
Et vous avez vos 3 bouts de papier classique.
Je vous laisse le faire,
je vais le faire en même temps que vous d'ailleurs !
Voilà ce que j'appelle "3 bouts de papier classique"
Vous les posez devant vous
Et vous les notez de 1 à 3
De la gauche vers la droite
Comme ça
et 3.
Vous les retournez tous
Et maintenant vous les numérotez de 4 à 6
Toujours de la gauche vers la droite
Donc comme ça
4, 5, 6
Et vous les posez devant vous
Le 4 étant le plus à votre gauche.
Et enfin vous les retournez encore une fois
Pour avoir devant vous
Les trois chiffres de 1 à 3
Celui de gauche étant le 1
Maintenant vous les mélangez de l'ordre que vous voulez
Allez-y mélangez, mélangez, mélangez
Vous mélangez autant que vous voulez,
Dans l'ordre que vous voulez
J'attend !
Maintenant, dans votre esprit, uniquement dans votre tête
Vous allez choisir celui de gauche, celui du milieu ou celui de droite
Dans votre tête, sans me dire lequel, vous en choisissez un mentalement.
Faites le maintenant !
Et retournez le !
Allez y ! Retournez celui que vous avez choisi dans votre tête.
Vous avez donc devant vous maintenant une combinaison unique
Je vais vous demander d'additionner tous ces chiffres entre eux,
Si vous 1 3 5, vous faites 1+3+5
Additionnez les 3 chiffres entre eux et gardez ce résultat dans votre tête.
On a presque terminé...Vous allez maintenant associer ce chiffre là à la lettre correspondante dans l'alphabet
Je vous aide, je vous l'ai dit c'est dimanche ça vous évitera de réfléchir trop...
Alors 1 c'est A, B c'est 2, C=3, D=4, E=5, F=6, G=7, H=8, I=9, J=10, K=11, L=12 ,M=13, N=14, O=15
Et ça ne peut pas allez plus loin parce que les 3 chiffres les plus gros que l'on ait noté sont 4,5,6.
Vous avez donc maintenant une lettre dans votre tête, une lettre dans votre esprit,
celle dont le rang de l'aphabet correspondait au résultat que vous aviez en tête.
Vous allez maintenant prendre le temps de penser à un animal qui commence par cette lettre...
Allez-y prenez le temps il y a des animaux qui existent pour toutes les lettres de l'alphabet donc cherchez,
cherchez un animal qui commence par cette lettre. Cela peut-être un mammifère,
ça peut-être un animal du quotidien,
ça peut-être un animal fermier comme une vache.
Ca peut-être un reptile comme les serpents, les lézards...
Trouvez un animal qui commence par cette lettre.
Et vous en avez un en tête maintenant, un et un seul.
Et laissez moi vous regardez, vous mentalisez parce que je pense,
qu'est-ce que je raconte je sais que vous êtes entrain de penser à un IGUANE !
Et que c'était pas si facile à trouver d'ailleurs un iguane! *clap clap clap*
Bravo c'est un bel effort et c'est surtout une belle réussite de votre part à vous!
Vous avez compris comme je fais sur certaines vidéos,
c'était encore une manière détournée de vous faire un forcage mathématiques
Pour aboutir à 9 puisque votre chiffre c'était 9
Et après j'ai appliqué ce principe bien connu des cours de récréation avec l'éléphant de Danemark
Donc vous avez juste à réaliser le tour exactement tel que je vous l'ai fait avec les feuilles de papier
les chiffres, la même méthode. Regardez la vidéo, apprenez ça comme ca,
Refaites le dès ce midi ou cette semaine à vos amis,à qui vous voulez et vous les blufferez!
Si cette vidéo vous à plu partagez la,
Mais je sais que vous partagez rarement les explications
et en même temps je comprends, je comprends que vous ne partagiez pas parce que
si vous la partagez après vous allez donner l'astuce à d'autres personnes!
Si vous la partagez pas pensez au moins à liker et à vous abonnez à cette chaîne!
Abonnez-vous, allez-y regardez, là, hop! Voilà cliquez,voilà, c'est très bien!
Vous pouvez également commenter pour me raconter comment ça c'est passé
quand vous l'avez fait à d'autres personnes j'adore lire ça!
Passez un excellent dimanche et on se retrouve demain pour le prochain mental vlog à 17h
Ciao!